life in a tent is exposed to all kinds
of weather but even these makeshift
homes are a blessing for hundreds of
thousands of Iraqis from Mosul what used
to be Iraq second largest city
eleven-year-old Othman Sultan was
blinded in one eye and suffered nerve
damage when he was hit by mortar
shrapnel yeah a foolish thought but mine
is now mentally challenged our house in
Mosul was leveled life is so hard and I
can go home there is nothing there here
in the camp we have access to services I
can't pay the rent outside the tent the
people of Mosul from north to south are
the victims of this war these flimsy
tents don't provide much protection
against the elements but more than
300,000 people continue to live in tents
like these many tried to go back to
Mosul but then came back to camps
because at least here they get some
security safety as well as food and
electricity in Mosul alone a hundred and
thirty-eight thousand homes were
destroyed while some have been repaired
more than 50 thousand are still
flattened after the bombardment it will
take many years and billions of dollars
to reconstruct and the displaced have
nowhere else to go the number one reason
that we hear is that their homes are
still destroyed and that they simply
cannot afford to rebuild their hoping
for assistance from the international
community and the government but it's
just it's so far insufficient in
addition to the destruction most of
these families carry the stigma of
having lived under ISIL the mostly Sunni
Muslims who fled Mosul are viewed with
suspicion and seen by some as icy
collaborators that lack of trust is an
obstacle to the return of the displaced
the UN's migration body says revenge
killings and retaliation against those
suspected of links with ISIL threatened
to trigger new cycles of inter-communal
violence the organization managing this
camp didn't allow us full access our
guides took notes of what people were
telling us and phoned someone to inform
them we were stopped from filming a
woman who said her husband was forced to
pledge allegiance to ISIL and
disappeared after Iraqi forces regained
control why did the Hussein's husband
was a policeman beheaded by ISIL she
struggles to provide for her seven
children and thinks he'll stay in the
camp for the foreseeable future I don't
have
pension my children need care they
require money to survive we are living
off charity and donations who eat and
dress whenever we receive help my house
is in a remote area and we can't go back
now
the area is abandoned and dangerous to
return too many families were killed
when they returned both mine and most of
his friends grew up under ISIL rule and
now feel ostracized that doesn't bode
well for the future of Mosul where
sectarian and tribal divisions run deep
some have enjoyed without Azera Jada
camp Muslim